Hey, if you haven't already got it. Get yourself a copy of answer the internet,
the card game it's available right now in the link in the bio,
or you can get at Barstool sports, Walmart, Amazon,
or Spencer gifts play along with us. Let's get it. What's up guys?
My name is Trevor Wallace. And today I'm here to answer the internet.
[Inaudible].
Number one. Would you put your kid in a gorilla pit for 50 K? Yes, bro. What?
This course, kids aren't even worth 50 K in general,
because if I get 50 K from my kid,
that's at least like private school for like what? Four years, bro. Gorillas,
not even that harmful.
Would you rather always have the hiccups or always have a headache.
I would rather commit suicide, bro. Both. Those are terrible. Uh,
I'm a go with always have a headache and just be addicted to Advil.
I'll just get a brand deal with Advil and just be popping. Cause hiccups.
Nobody likes it. Any with hiccups. Shut up, dude.
Cause everybody's offering you water all the time. As a kid,
my mom used to give me a spoonful of sugar and she'd be like,
that gets rid of it. I was like, it gets rid of hiccups,
but it gives you diabetes. Mom, do you want me on this planet or not? You know,
if you came across a glory hole, would you put your Dick in it? Yes,
because honestly, no,
I was thinking about this the other day.
Like you don't come across them all that often. You know, it's like,
I've seen Mount Rushmore. I've been to the grand Canyon,
but never once have I been like, that's a glory hole right there,
plus you never know who's knocking on the other side.
So if I'm in there and I get a tick on the other side, bro,
that's look, I was, I want to try a glory hole.
But that's kind of the point. You don't know what's on the other side.
So you know what if it's like.
But there's a wall in front of you, so Hey, it's 2019, whatever it's touching,
it's touching it. You know,
would you rather be hairless or never be able to cut your own hair,
I'm going, never cut my own hair.
Cause I seen a lot of dudes in Venice that looked like,
but they really long hair and they've really hot girlfriend.
And then I would just invest in like a CBD, like dog food company.
And then just make racks off that because bald dudes, you have to do porn.
That's the only option you have to do porn or managing auto zone.
And I'm going long hair hippie, you know,
would you rather your mom or daughter be a porn star? God it. Um,
I'm going to have to go with my food.
it. Um, I am God.
I'm doing my mom's a porn star because then I had a better childhood.
Cause she had porn star money.
Now I get to ride a school and a C class Mercedes you know everybody's like,
what does your mom do? Is she, she broadcasted for CBS? I'm like,
she's a broadcaster for Dick. I'll tell you that much.
She broadcasts a sunlight, but th but see, cause if your daughter's a porn star,
everybody, you're the butt end of the joke.
And then what you come across at one late night. Oh,
it's your own couch in the video. And you're like,
I thought that was gravy staying on the couch.
You might make me sit in your own. Okay. Yeah, mom for sure. Ooh.
First one to do this question.
Would you rather let your wife you once with a strap on or take her last name?
When you get married? Hear me out, bro.
I'm gonna start off this answer by saying no homo, but she me.
All right. One time. You don't have to tell anybody,
but if you take her last name, you getting every day, bro.
Every time you put it, we got it to go order for Trevor, uh, Carlston Wallace.
You don't have to say the full part. Chara Carlston was Carmel macchiato.
I said, Trevor, um, yeah, you're doing one. You just taking the, but once.
Oh, if everybody did know.
So you either got her last name or you walk in and it's like,
that's the guy who gets butterflies.
All right, last name. It is bro.
But I'm married to a girl that has the same last name as me.
So it sounds like I got to start over and I'm like, Oh yeah, I'm Trevor Wallace,
Wallace. Is he mentally right in the head?
Would you rather always come prematurely or never come at all?
I'm going, never come at all. Because then if it goes like,
are you close to finishing it again? I'm sorry. I'm just tired.
You know the classic I'm tired has gotten me out of so many,
just drunken nights where the dig don't work. But if you come,
if you come too quick, then you always gotta have a sob story.
Like I was stressed out. I had too many emails at work. It was windy outside.
I got nervous. The Lakers lost my fantasy teammate and doing too well.
Every time I do nuts too early,
they always got like a background story to back it up. I do that every time.
If I'm under a minute, unlike my grandmother just passed away.
And the sand of your skin reminded me of her funeral. And then she's like, baby,
you don't have to talk about that. We're fine. You know,
it was windy a lot and I was nervous, bro. Blame it on the, uh, blame,
my mother nature. Would you rather a never get oral sex ever again,
or be only, or get only oral sex for the rest of your life?
Wait, both of these are great, but what the?
No oral ever again,
the only thing you can do is you can't have regular sex.
Oh, okay. I see what you're saying. Um,
never get oral again, bro. Um, you know? Yeah.
That one's just straight up, you know, I don't head,
doesn't always do it for me.
And then the girls always get self-conscious they're like, is it me?
And I'm like, Hmm.
[Inaudible].
Uh, but yeah, I'm, I'm, I'm sticking straight up to that.
Would you rather be only able to eat cream cheese or catch up? You know what
it says on the bottom 56% of Barstool readers choose cream cheese.
I'm going to go with cream cheese on that ketchup. See it had, they put like,
um, barbecue sauce here. I'll go. Barbecue sauce, big barbecue sauce guy.
It's like catch-up with CrossFit behind it. Um, um, cream cheese.
I don't know what the you put it on besides bagels.
And is there anything else you put it in? Well, I guess I'm going to find out.
Cause all the. I mean the rest of my life, I like cream cheese. Okay.
Would you rather be good looking? I am and always have nice clothes,
but smell like or look like a homeless person,
but always smell nice.
Wow.
Well here's the thing in 2019, the you look the richer you look right.
That's Kanye, his motto right there. His drip is what he's going by.
So kind of earlier with like the long hair question, I'm going look like,
but smell good. Cause you throw a Gucci logo on it and then they're like, Oh,
is that the new Gucci drunk? It is. It's not,
but it's would you rather a always feel like you have to or
be never know when you're about to.
I'm going to go be I would never like to know.
Cause that that feeling of always have to is constant anxiety. It's like,
it's like being, Oh, you can't control it. You never know.
But when you feel it, you can't run to a bathroom, man.
There's nothing worse than always feeling like you have this. Like I see it.
Like whenever I'm at a girl's house and I know I have this and the toilet's just
staring at me and she's just sitting there at her house is dead silent.
Girls' house is always so quiet when you have to.
So I'm just sitting there holding it and just drinking a coffee.
She's like you could to go for this two hour ride to San Diego. No,
we need to get gas. The car is full. It's a Tesla. Best pull over.
I need to use the bathroom. God honestly, man. I hate that anxiety.
Cause I drink a lot of coffee and knowing you have this is just knowing she
would have to awkwardly feel terrible.
Would you rather be able to any girl you wanted or teleport anywhere in the
world?
Hear me out. Teleport.
If you can teleport, you can whatever bro. Cause I'm thinking you can be like,
Hey, sorry. I just got back from my meeting in Guam.
W did you want to get drinks? Oh, I'm sorry.
I got to leave in five minutes to go to Bay route. Are we still on for this?
You're like, she probably thinks you got teleportation money.
So you plus God it.
There is so many times where I'm just 30 minutes late to a meeting sitting in
the car. Like if I could just thin this outta here. Um.
Also.
I was just sat on the bottom. How many Barstool readers?
Because every Barstool supported him. He was always like, Aw, any girl, bro.
anything.
I'm going to teleport and hope and banking on the fact that girls have a King
for teleportation. There's there's gotta be some shake out there.
Would you rather watch only softcore porn for the rest of your life?
That HBO money right there or only minor league sports for the rest of your
life. Okay.
Uh, I'm going.
Yay. Cause soft core. I like soft core. Cause it gets your imagination working.
It makes you feel like what love really feels like. You know?
Cause the soft core I heard on HBO, they're not actually penetrating.
They're just rubbing. And that gives me hope for the future. You know?
Cause I watched porn I now and I'm like, marriage, why the would I do that?
But you watch enough soft core. You're like, yeah,
I could go to Paris with a girl. You know, I could fall in love.
I could eat a baguette with Stephanie. You know,
if you had the chance to the perfect girl,
but you had to do it with your entire family in the room watching,
would you do it? Yes.
The perfect girl because the perfect girl to me is going to be like a
girl like Halle Berry, my family, my dad is cheering me on like bro.
Yes or Laura Croft. You know, they're like tomb, Raider.
My dad's in the background being like, that's my son. My mom's just like,
well at least he's getting paid. You know,
my cousins is filming it for PornHub amateur. You know like it's all wins.
Would you rather permanently be on stilts or permanently?
Have phone fingers on each hand?
Ah, God it. I'm going foam fingers. Ah.
Foam fingers kind of suck because everybody thinks you're well.
Yeah. Well.
Um.
Bro, cause you remember me of drunk on stilts. You're losing your,
your front four teeth immediately. You're, I'm doing,
here's why I'm doing faint.
The foam fingers because you can legally be drunk whenever you want,
because everybody's like, Oh he just left. Oh a Marlins game.
You know like he's good bro. Like he he's, he's always at a sporting event.
And plus when the girl's like, so do you want to like finger me?
Like I wish I could, but it looks like you got to go down on me. So by default,
I just want to get a phone finger. Um, yes, stills, that.
Who would win in a street? Fight. Mike vinegar. Timothy.
All right.
Where's the fight take place. If it's on a Sunday, Tim Tebow whooping his, bro.
He got the power of the Lord and every Chick-fil-A employee behind his back.
Just strapped up. Ready with that Polynesian sauce.
Any other day of the week Mike Vick bro. Mike Vick.
I feel like he could take on a small country.
I feel like Mike Vick has single-handedly take down like Atlantic city or
something. Would you rather have all music or all TV be in Spanish? Oh.
I'm going to TV.
I love me a good telling the Webber. The love on there bro.
I don't know what the is going on, but the stakes are always so high.
Somebody's always cheating.
Somebody is like always crying and it's it's good cinema, you know? Um,
but if I, if I only listened to Spanish music,
then I just want to drink all the time. It's way too.
Like I feel like I should be on Molly, just Gasolina in this. You know,
if you saw that one of your friends accidentally posted a Dick pic on Snapchat,
would you tell him or would you have him leave it up? That depends.
Does he owe me money? All right. 20 bucks and below I'm telling him,
but if he tells me like 50 bucks,
I'm leaving and he leaving that up there or I'm,
here's what I'm actually going to do screenshot. And now I got blackmail, right?
He was like, Hey man, would you mind driving to the game tonight?
I want it to drink a little bit. I'll be like, Oh,
you want it to drink a little bit?
We should have done that before he whooped a Dick out and bathroom last weekend.
You know? So I'm using that as a, as a I'm using it as blackmail for sure.